vielen dank nach mainz und guten abend
gegen zu haus zu dieser sondersendung
hunderttausende haben heute in berlin
für frieden demonstriert und für die
freiheit der ukraine eigentlich sind
sich alle in diesem ziel aber wie ist es
noch zu erreichen jetzt da russische
truppen ukrainische städte beschießen
jetzt da bleibt mir putin seine
atomstreitkräfte in alarmbereitschaft
versetzt beschlossen sind sanktionen
waffen für die ukraine auch seit gestern
um seit heute milliarden für die
bundeswehr wird das reichen und helfen
wir müssen reden mit diesen gästen
kevin kühn spd generalsekretär
die deutsch ukrainische politikerin
marina weisband
andré wüstner chef des
bundeswehrverbandes
der cdu-politiker roderich kiesewetter
und
robin alexander
stellvertretender chefredakteur der welt
sie sind zu gast bei maybrit illner
und die begrüßt die gäste der sendung
heute hier sehr herzlich bevor wir mit
der diskussion staaten ein interview mit
annalena baerbock der bundes
außenministerin dass wir kurz vor der
sendung geführt haben
guten abend frau burke wir verstehen
heute dass wladimir putin seine
atomstreitkräfte in alarmbereitschaft
versetzt ist das nicht die maximale
eskalation jetzt herr putin hat das
potenzial auch bisher die ukraine der
ukraine schlimmstes anzutun und deswegen
agieren wir als internationale
gemeinschaft so geschlossen dagegen und
arbeiten mit allen kräften daran das
regime von herrn putin zu isolieren
plötzlich schickt die deutsche regierung
waffen frau werburg 1000
panzerabwehrwaffen 500 boden raketen vom
typ sting bleibt nicht denn noch am ende
hängen das ist alles zu wenig und es
kommt viel zu spät
stand ist dass putin diesen krieg mit
allem was er hatte wollte keine
sanktionen keine waffenlieferung zuvor
hätte das aufhalten können aber so
fassungslos wie uns das macht das
bedeutet nicht dass wir ohnmächtig sind
sondern dass wir als weltgemeinschaft
gemeinsam agieren können und durch
diesen angriffskrieg den niemand von uns
wollte sondern nur putin allein sind wir
in einer anderen welt und wenn die welt
eine andere ist da muss auch die politik
eine andere sein die ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer haben nichts getan sie wollten
einfach in frieden und in freiheit leben
putin hat sie angegriffen überfallen wir
erleben familien in u-bahn-schächten
kleine kinder die unsere kinder sein
könnten mitten in europa und deswegen
müssen wir uns dem entgegenstellen und
die ukraine bei ihrem recht auf
selbstverteidigung was in der un-charta
verbrieft ist jetzt unterstützen und ja
ich habe vor ein paar wochen gesagt wenn
man eine 180 grad wendung in der
außenpolitik macht dann muss man das bei
vollem bewusstsein machen in dem moment
wo nichts anderes mehr geht und wir
haben bis zuletzt an die diplomatie
geglaubt sie vertreten aber putin wollte
das nicht und jetzt unterstützen wir die
ukraine bei ihrem kampf auf
selbstverteidigung es hieß frau burke
die bundeswehr hätte gar nichts
anzubieten plötzlich findet man
tatsächlich panzerabwehrwaffen und auch
raketen wer stand er bis zuletzt auf der
bremse haben sie olaf scholz haben sie
den bundeskanzler da zum jagen tragen
müssen
wir haben zu recht eine außen- und
sicherheitspolitik die auch
verhältnismäßigkeit setzt die auf
ausgleiche setzt und deswegen auch eine
sehr restriktive rüstungs und
exportkontrolle politik aber wir haben
erlebt dass sich herr putin an keine
regeln des internationalen rechts mehr
hält wir erleben dass unschuldige
menschen dafür jetzt bezahlen müssen und
deswegen haben wir in dieser zeitenwende
entschieden dass wir jetzt die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer gemeinsam
unterstützen ja von seiten der
bundeswehr können wir ein teil dazu
beitragen nicht wahnsinnig viel aber
gemeinsam mit anderen internationalen
partnern die ukraine unterstützen aber
es ist eben nicht nur die frage jetzt
die ukraine bei der selbstverteidigung
zu unterstützen sondern vor allen dingen
auch mit humanitärer hilfe jetzt
verlieren den ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
aufzunehmen und vor allen dingen das ist
mir extrem wichtig russland zu isolieren
wir machen deutlich dieser krieg den
russland jetzt führt und zwar der
präsident gegen den willen von vielen
menschen in seinem eigenen land der wird
für das russische regime in zukunft
unbezahlbar werden weil er wird russland
komplett isolieren und wirtschaftlich
ruinieren und dafür ist der russische
präsident alleine verantwortlich noch
mal die frage man hält ihnen zugute frau
berbalk da wesentlich klarer gesprochen
zu haben und auch früher gesprochen zu
haben als der deutsche bundeskanzler der
ukrainische botschafter in deutschland
hat olaf scholz kritisiert als zu
kaltherzig und zu und empathisch in der
frage der verteidigung der ukraine und
jetzt kümmern wir uns dann also
wenigstens um die flüchtlinge
nein aber stimmt doch nicht wir haben
heute eine sondersitzung des deutschen
bundestags gehabt und so eine
entscheidung die trifft man ja nicht
nebenbei und ich glaube man kann mir an
merkt man kann aber auch der gesamten
bundesregierung anmerken und den
hunderttausenden von menschen die heute
auf der straße
darin dass das doch eigentlich
unvorstellbar ist meine generation viele
viele junge menschen die hatten das
große glück nie krieg erleben zu müssen
und jetzt ist es plötzlich passiert der
angriffskrieg ist nach europa
zurückgekehrt und das ist ein moment der
uns alle wie gesagt fassungslos macht
aber wir müssen handeln und wir müssen
die ukraine unterstützen und deswegen
tun wir das mit einem wahnsinnig großen
sanktionspaket diese sanktionen so
ehrlich muss man sein können putin
gerade nicht stoppen weil er den wahn
hat auch nicht die 100 milliarden für
die deutsche verteidigung also für die
deutsche bundeswehr das alles braucht
viel zeit noch mal die frage kommt die
deutsche hilfe nicht zu spät
wie gesagt wir haben leider erleben
müssen die amerikaner haben ja waffen
geliefert die briten und andere haben
auch waffen geliefert das hat ja ein
putin nicht davon abgeschreckt er wollte
auf teufel komm raus diesen krieg koste
es was es wolle und wir haben mit allem
versucht diesen krieg zu verhindern weil
krieg ist das aller schlimmste was
passieren kann das erlebt man doch
gerade unschuldige menschen kommen zu
tode und jetzt werden wir alles tun und
tun alles und das ist ein moment in
unserer geschichte den wir so nicht
kommen haben sehen aber jetzt müssen wir
handeln und die ukrainerinnen und
ukrainer unterstützen aber das wird
nicht allein mit waffenlieferungen
erreicht sein deswegen ist es so wichtig
auf allen kanälen
das russische regime zu isolieren das
ist jetzt die herausnahme der
zentralbank aus dem swift system
beziehungsweise die banken aus dem 12
system einfrieren von konten oligarchen
die nicht mehr in europa einkaufen
können immobilien besitzen können die
wirtschafts kanäle abschneiden und ich
habe heute im deutschen bundestag
appelliert an die weltgemeinschaft es
geht nicht nur um europa es geht um das
internationale recht kein land der welt
kann ein interesse daran haben dass
jetzt das russische regime damit
durchkommt dass der stärkere nachbar
seinen anderen schwächeren nachbarn
überfallen kann deswegen müssen wir als
weltgemeinschaft jetzt ganz entschlossen
und geschlossen dagegen halten und
deutlich machen das hat massive und zwar
langfristige wirtschaftliche finanzielle
und damit auch politische konsequenzen
für dieses regime stehen vor einer
zeitenwende russische und ukrainische
verhandler sollen sich in belarus
treffen frau bernburg noch eine letzte
kurze frage worum kann es in diesen
gesprächen gehen und rechnen sie damit
irgendeinem ergebnis präsident schon mal
nicht
jan trotzdem nehmen die ukraine jetzt
auf niedriger ebene daran teil und das
ist auch richtig so weil die menschen in
ihrem land sterben wir haben gesehen
dass der russische präsident alle
belogen hat deswegen wenn er
gleichzeitig bombardiert auch waffen
einsetzt die man sich nicht hätte
vorstellen können
dann kann man kaum glauben dass das
ernsthafte gespräche sein werden aber
jetzt müssen wir die ukrainische
regierung unterstützen und wenn es nur
den funken hoffnung gibt dass die waffen
schweigen können dann muss man diese
chance nutzen und zeitgleich machen wir
uns nichts vor und wie gesagt deswegen
haben wir heute gemeinsam entschieden im
deutschen bundestag ganz ganz preis in
großer einigkeit im deutschen bundestag
wir stehen solidarisch mit allem was wir
haben an der seite der ukraine alle
müssen zugeständnisse machen auch die
parteien die fdp wird schulden machen
müssen die fdp die spd wird über die den
schatten springen müssen auch über
rüstungen und aufrüstungen wieder
nachzudenken und die grünen werden
länger kohle verheizen müssen
ja das ist der preis den auch wir zahlen
für diesen krieg von herrn putin aber es
ist nichts dagegen was die menschen in
der ukraine erleben müssen wir haben
familien wo die väter nicht aus dem land
können wo die mütter mit den kindern
jetzt zum glück über die grenze kommen
können ganz ganz viele können aber eben
nicht fliehen und in dieser situation
das habe ich ja vor einigen tagen und
wochen bereits deutlich gemacht dass
wird auch einen preis für uns hier haben
wirtschaftlich finanziell aber es ist
richtig dass wir diesen preis bezahlen
weiß er ist nichts dagegen was in der
ukraine gerade passiert und wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass dieses furchtbare
barbarische treiben ein ende hat und
daher ist es so richtig dass wir die
entscheidung heute getroffen haben im
wirtschafts im finanz aber eben auch im
militärischen bereich
danke für dieses gespräch danke ebenso
alles gute
und damit zurück in der runde bei uns
ist andré wüstner oberst im einsatz
gewesen im kosovo und in afghanistan
herr wiesner sie sind der chef des
deutschen bundeswehrverbandes
putin versetzt seine atomstreitkräfte in
alarmbereitschaft das war auch eine
nachricht des heutigen tages die
russische armee kann noch viel brutaler
noch viel massakrieren da
sicherlich zu gange gegen zu werke gehen
wie sehr befürchten sie dass die jetzige
situation ist schon besorgniserregend in
jeglicher hinsicht klar das stimmt der
russische angriffschwung ist gestoppt
worden ist verlangsamt worden und nichts
desto trotz muss man wissen er hat noch
viel power in der hinterhand der führt
jetzt diese kräfte run deswegen will ich
auch skeptisch was diese option der
verhandlungen anbelangt das kann man ja
auch nutzen um kräfte in dieser zeit
weiter heran zu führen es liegt aber
auch daran muss man hier klar zum
ausdruck bringen dass die ukraine besser
kämpfen
wahnsinnig sozusagen sich den russen
gegenüberstehe gegenüberstellen und ja
also den russen wesentlich mehr
entgegenstellen als diese erwartet haben
was die atomare option anbelangt das
besorgt auch mich denn da laufen
russische u-boote aus im nordmeer
bestückt mit mittelstreckenraketen
interkontinentalraketen man kann zwar
sagen diese stufe hatten wir auch mal im
zuge der annexion der krim und
nichtsdestotrotz weiß man nicht wie
putin agiert er agiert irrational und
deswegen kommt es jetzt auf aufklärung
an man muss das täglich genau beobachten
es gut dass der nachrichtendienst gut
aufgeschaltet ist aber es treibt mich um
und das durchsuchen des schutts
überhaupt einen marina weisband
bündnisgrüne geboren in kiew es uns auch
heute abend aus münster zugeschaltet
marine an den guten abend zu ihnen
deutschland liefert jetzt waffen an die
ukraine man denkt nicht nur über
sanktionen nach sondern auch über andere
maßnahmen in europa und in der welt ist
die regierung die deutsche regierung hat
sich bewegt wird dass die den menschen
in kiew und in häfen
heute noch nicht unmittelbar
aber ich höre erleichterung aus der
ukraine und das hat damit zu tun dass
natürlich diese zwei dinge also
einerseits waffenlieferungen die den
preis des krieges für putin immer höher
treiben andererseits die sanktionen
eine andere einen anderen kampf sterben
der gerade passiert es ist ja nicht nur
so dass in der ukraine gekämpft wird ich
denke ein zweiter wichtiger kampf ist
jetzt gerade innerhalb russlands wo ein
guter teil gerade der jüngeren der
städtischen bevölkerung schon lange
gegen diesen krieg ist und je länger
kiew stand hält desto mehr sickert diese
information durch wir haben den großen
vorteil dass auch die russischen
soldaten ja eigentlich nicht dort
kämpfen wollen die wissen ja überhaupt
nicht wofür sie da sind sie dachten sie
würden in der ukraine mit brot und salz
begrüßt als die großen befreier von dem
neo nazi regime und an der stelle sind
sie opfer ihrer eigenen propaganda
geworden und meine große große hoffnung
ist dass die stimmung in russland kippt
und natürlich wenn die ukraine länger
durchhält je länger sie durchhält desto
mehr verbreitet sich in der russischen
medienlandschaft in der russischen
mundpropaganda was dort wirklich
passiert und ich denke putin kann an der
stelle am besten von seinem eigenen volk
aufgehalten werden die deutsche
regierung hat sich bewegt robin
alexander stellvertretender
chefredakteur der welt und heute abend
bei uns wir haben uns entschieden die
ukraine allein zu lassen haben sie noch
am donnerstag gesagt ist dass ab heute
anders ab gestern des tages ist die
entscheidung gefallen ganz dramatisch so
sagen ja noch bis in den nachmittag so
aus dass deutschland völlig isoliert ist
die niederländer haben gesagt dürfen wir
wenigsten waffen liefern die ihr mal
gebaut habt
deutschlandweit
war das letzte land das sich gegen das
abschneiden von dieses system bewährt
hat und erkennbar haben viele leute im
politischen berlin nicht gedacht dass
die ukraine so lange durchhalten die
dachten nach der invasion die klappen
zusammen und dann kann man mit putin
wieder verhandeln und der groschen ist
in deutschland wahnsinnig langsam
gefallen aber als er dann gefallen ist
hatte einen großen auf knall gemacht
weil was die bundesregierung das
verändert hat ist wirklich immens und
das hat wieder einen effekt weil
deutschland eben vorher diese ganz
andere position hatte glaube ich mache
das auch sehr sehr großen eindruck und
ich glaube nicht dass putin das für
möglich gehalten hatte und damit sind
wir bei kevin kühnert generalsekretär
der spd erinnert olaf scholz hat sehr
sehr lange gezögert der ukraine waffen
zu liefern er ist damit nicht nur von
anderen politikern in diesem land
kritisiert worden sondern offensichtlich
eben auch von verbündeten in europa
jetzt liefern wir waffen kann man wird
am ende übrig bleiben und das war auch
meine frage an die bundes
außenministerin dass wir das einfach
hängen bleibt dass wir zu spät um die
ecke kam dass wir zu wenig und zu spät
geliefert haben
am ende wird die geschichte immer
darüber urteilen wie die abläufe gewesen
sind aber ich kann rechtfertigen ich
glaube wir alle können rechtfertigen
warum diese entscheidung jetzt gefallen
ist die lage hat sich zu einem zeitpunkt
ganz wesentlich und nachweislich
geändert und das war in der nacht von
mittwoch auf donnerstag das ist der
moment in dem herr putin den einmarsch
in die ukraine befehligt hat und in dem
die truppen in das land in das noch
nicht toll besetzte land
hinein gekommen sind und in diesem
moment war klar unsere ehrenwerten und
richtigen versuche als ein land was
davon ausgegangen ist im kreml noch
gehört zu finden vielleicht noch den
letzten funken von nutzbaren putin
hervor kitzeln zu können dass das nicht
funktioniert in diesem moment war klar
jetzt muss eine andere strategie
funktionieren wenn er liefern sie hier
können sie jetzt waffen aus überzeugung
oder aus gruppenzwang durch die
verbündeten nein aus überzeugung weil
kein besseres mittel auch im moment zur
verfügung steht ich finde das nicht
ehrenrührig zu sagen ist fällt manchen
von uns nicht leicht zu sagen man
liefert in krisengebiete waffen aber man
muss hier einst also das ist keine
leichtfertige angelegenheit niemand muss
jubeln deswegen man darf dabei ein stör
gefühl haben und trotzdem ist das eine
richtige entscheidung weil herr putin
und sein enger zirkel der diese
entscheidung jetzt noch trifft keinerlei
vernunft begabung mehr an den tag legt
es gibt keine berechtigte hoffnung in
diesen stunden und minuten dass
irgendein gesprächsangebot irgendein
opfer eine opfergabe die man ihm noch
bringen könnte zu einer relevanten
verhaltensänderung führen würde und dann
muss die entscheidung für die tapfer
kämpfenden menschen in der ukraine in
diesem moment fallen und das ist die
entscheidung für waffenlieferung oder
rich kiesewetter ist bayerns
außenpolitiker der cdu oberst r de herr
kiesewetter die frage ist natürlich
sanktionen waffenlieferungen da sind
heute viele kegel gefallen auch im
deutschen bundestag mit großen reden
angekündigt und verteidigt und vertreten
milliarden auch für die bundeswehr all
das wird jetzt aktuellen natürlich nicht
helfen und wird also wie sehr wladimir
putin beeindrucken ich glaube dass ein
ganz starkes signal europäischer
einigung auch transatlantische einigung
und vom bundestag heute ist auch ein
signal der staatstragenden parteien
ausgegangen dass wir hinter der
regierung stehen putin sieht die
entschlossenheit des westens und vor
allen dingen millionen von ukrainern
sind auf der flucht innerhalb des landes
hunderttausende kommen nach europa und
sie sehen jetzt endlich das auch das
wichtigste und stärkste land innerhalb
europas deutschland den schulterschluss
gefunden hat und wir mithelfen also
unter dem strich glaube ich es heute ein
tag der wende der auch bei uns die
sicherheitspolitik auf jahre verändern
wird sie müssen uns auch in noch mal
helfen bevor wir zu diesem historischen
ereignis kommen wo hat denn die
bundesregierung jetzt plötzlich diese
waffen gefunden es hieß ja immer wir
hätten die überhaupt gar nicht zur
verfügung wo waren die system ja wo sind
die luft boden abwehrraketen gefunden
und die sind natürlich bei der
bundeswehr aber die bundeswehr ist an
der grenze ihrer möglichkeiten
sie hat auch nur sehr gering
ausstattungen aber die geben wir jetzt
her dass spricht panzerfäuste oder auch
station wir haben in bestimmten bestand
und davon
wie ein viertel ab das ist ein das sind
luftabwehrfeuer waffen die man von hand
aus abfeuern kann aber hier geht es
nicht um die einzelheiten es geht darum
wir haben bestände und wir helfen und
ich glaube auch dass die deutsche
rüstungsindustrie stadt nach katar oder
in die vereinigten arabischen emirate zu
liefern viel wichtiger ein land
unterstützt das vor dem zusammenbruch
steht aber für die regelbasierte ordnung
außenpolitischen gründen sind sie nicht
in die eu gekommen und das müssen wir
ändern wir stehen an der seite der
ukraine die ukraine hat sich lange
darüber beklagt robin alexander die hat
gesagt im grunde sind 2008 und dann auch
2015 durch europa wenn nicht sogar durch
deutschlands verhindert worden dass die
ukraine sich bewaffnen konnte und sich
verteidigen konnte wie schwer wiegt
dieser vorwurf in all unseren reden
momentan
2008 gab es die idee dass die ukraine in
die nato aufgenommen das war damals eine
andere kann ihre initiative und das ist
tatsächlich maßgeblich von der
bundesregierung verhindert worden durch
ein veto aber ich muss dazu sagen ich
fand damals dass auch klug weil die idee
dass die ukraine die ein land das mit
großen inneren spannung auch also ich
fand die politik die damals federführend
von angela merkel und frank walter
steinmeier gemacht hat immer wieder in
den dialog zu gehen immer wieder zu
versuchen selbst nach dem die
separatisten im donbass wagen dann
versuchen die so eine realistische
kleinteilige sache zu gehen ich fand das
immer richtig aber trotzdem muss ich
doch heute sagen es ist gescheitert es
hilft doch nichts und so die politik die
deutschland gemacht hat merkel
steinmeier schon daran angesetzt ist
gescheitert und es gibt leute im
baltikum in polen amerikaner die haben
uns das vorher gesagt und das gehört
dazu dass wir sagen müssen die hatten
recht und wir haben geehrt
wir sind marina weisband in der
situation die
ukrainische menschen männer wie frauen
familien zu bewundern natürlich für
ihren mut und auch für den kampf
was wird es verändern an diesem
kräftegleichgewicht oder an diesem
ungleichgewicht david gegen goliath man
würde es eigentlich nicht in den mund
nehmen
also im moment ist es so dass russland
nur mit ungefähr der hälfte seiner
feuerkraft agiert hat und im moment ist
es noch so dass die soldaten auch den
befehl hatten möglichst zivilisten zu
verschonen und das kann sich natürlich
ändern das heißt
einerseits kommt mir unterstützung aus
dem westen auf der anderen seite kann
auch russland noch weit eskalieren also
eskalationspotenzial ist leider immer
noch da ich mache mit jahr über sehr
große sorgen
was ich nicht sehe ist dass die ukraine
kapitulieren wird also längst kann das
überhaupt nicht er kann er kann sich das
politisch nicht leisten wird das auch
nicht tun die menschen haben seinerzeit
schon auf dem majdan gestanden und
gekämpft und sind nicht gewichen und sie
werden diesmal nicht weichen ich erlebe
ja mit in meiner familie
das da sich wirklich darauf vorbereitet
wird die straße für straße zu
verteidigen also das wird eine ganz ganz
hässliche sache wenn wir weiter vor und
was wenn putin nun nicht nur die
stadtkirche umzingelt und die stadt
attraktiv umzingelt sondern mit atom
anschlägen droht
als einerseits ist es tatsächlich so
dass er ich höre immer gern russische
propaganda weil ich dann ungefähr weiß
worauf man sich einzustellen hat meiner
meinung nach hat der westen das viel zu
lange nicht gemacht bei uns wurde nicht
berichtet was dort abends im fernsehen
läuft heute abend vor einer stunde etwa
lief wieder zur primetime eine sendung
die ausgerechnet hat wie schnell
russland in der lage ist die usa zu
vernichten und zu radioaktivem staub zu
verwandeln das ist ein zitat das heißt
putin bereitet seit jahren im prinzip
seine eigene bevölkerung auf diesen
schritt vor das der anderen nationen mit
atomwaffen bedroht auf der anderen seite
putin ist in die ecke getrieben und er
ist soweit in die ecke getrieben
gegenüber seinen eigenen oligarchen
gegenüber seinen eigenen leuten
gegenüber dem ausland seinen verbündeten
im ausland sogar china dass er im
prinzip mit dem rücken zur wand steht
und er hat nur noch eine wache über die
er wirklich verfügt und das ist unsere
angst und ich persönlich weigere mich
ihm meine angst zu geben
und damit sind wir herr kiesewetter
wieder bei der frage das ist
bewundernswert und das möchte man nicht
das möchte man auch nicht sich nur
vorstellen und insofern ist die
tapferkeit der ukraine da sehr zu
bewundern noch mal heute abend heute am
tag droht wladimir putin eben mit auch
seine atomaren kraft die mit jedem rad
auf der friedensnobelpreisträger und
chefredakteur der nowaja gaseta sagt
putin drehe am atom knopf wie am
schlüsselbund eines teuren autos
womit kann man einem mann jetzt noch
drohen der offensichtlich nicht mehr
rational erklärt sondern der 33 klar ist
die lage bedenklich aber wir sollten da
wirklich besonnen bleiben und einem ganz
einfachen grund er führt die selbe
eskalation durch wie 2014 er hat von
vier möglichen bereitschafts geraten den
zweiten erreicht also die alarmierung
der streitkräfte aber er würde sich
damit dramatisch isolieren und er wird
auch nicht den rückhalt von china
bekommen die in solchen fragen äußerst
zurückhaltend sind wir sollten vielmehr
beobachten wie verhält sich russland in
moldawien heute ist etwas passiert in
weißrussland weißrussland hat seinen
status als atomwaffenfreie macht
aufgegeben ab morgen kann russland dort
nuklearwaffen stationieren wir müssen
aufpassen dass wir geschlossen stehen
dass sich nicht finnland und schweden
erpressen lassen falls sie in die nato
wollen und dass wir alles tun dass das
baltikum sich weiter sicher fühlt dort
sind viele russische frau weiß band
klang es ja an sind viele
russischsprachige russischstämmige
einwohnerinnen und einwohner und da geht
es einfach darum dass der
gesellschaftliche zusammenhalt stimmt
also nicht nur auf militärische
sicherheit achten sondern auch auf
sozialen zusammenhalt und das ist ein
spagat den wir schaffen als reiches land
in europa also wenn ich ihn jetzt aber
zu höre dann habe ich gehört dass sie
sagen es ist durchaus bedenkenswert was
da heute in weißrussland geschah und
offensichtlich bereitet sich putin
tatsächlich darauf vor eben dann auch
aus weißrussland atomare abschreckung zu
können und wir müssen auch das baltikum
schützens ist die nato dazu überhaupt in
der lage entschuldigung wenn ich das so
frage und wie lange man bei der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz hat die nato ihren
bereitschafts grad erhöht die nato
feuerwehr wie wir sie nennen die
schnelle eingreiftruppe ist aktiviert
sie wird jetzt verlegt wenn wir nun
relativ kleinen teil im baltikum das in
etwa 4000 so daniel wüstner viel besser
aber die nato feuerwehr die hat über
30.000 soldaten die werden jetzt
stationiert die bundeswehr ist mit
schiffen aber eben auch mit patriot
abwehrraketen mit infanterie und später
mit einem kampfgruppen bataillon dabei
das zeigt die ganze nato alle 28 nato
staaten zeigen da geschlossenheit und
das ist auch eine sprache die putin
versteht er hat sich völlig verschätzt
hat gedacht die nato spaltet sich die
straße ist voll von protesten sie sind
voll mit menschen die für die ukraine
demonstrieren heute hunderttausende in
berlin und damit sind wir noch mal bei
herrn wüstner truppen verlegen
alarmbereitschaft kann die nato einen
konventionellen angriff auf eines der
mitglieder abwehren und könnte die nato
auch einen atomaren angriff abwehren
automessen andere dimensionen aber zu
beginn steht ja das konventionelle und
wenn man konventionell in einem patt ist
dann ist es auch wesentlich schwieriger
für die ein oder andere seite gezwungen
zu sein so die argumentation atomar
tätig zu werden aber sind wir denn in
einem patt naja konventionell sind wir
jetzt gerade dabei die ostflanke zu
verstärken das machen wir
überdimensional schnell mit der
sogenannten schnellen eingreiftruppe der
nato 30 50.000 die jetzt relativ schnell
verlegt werden wir haben einen anteil
von rund 14.000 soldaten soldaten die
ersten sind schon vor ort diese woche
brechen einige auf in die slowakei
zusätzlich nach liter und zum erkunden
und wie herr kiesewetter gesagt hatte
also bodentruppen wir haben eurofighter
wir haben die eine andere korvette und
vieles mehr jetzt in der verstärkung um
zu zeigen nicht nur wir sind geschlossen
wir stehen zusammen sondern sind auch
schnell präsent wenn es darum geht
unsere bündnispartner auch die
sicherheit zu geben die sie auch
brauchen stichwort resilienz stichwort
widerstandsfähigkeit alles was dazu
gehört und das funktioniert besser als
herr putin dachte und ich glaube das
irritiert ihn gleichermaßen wir sind
natürlich erinnert uns auch bewusst dass
man der bundesregierung unter angela
merkel
vorwerfen konnte oder konzedieren konnte
besonders viel geduld mit wladimir putin
zu haben aber warum hat man jetzt
ausgerechnet bei der spd das gefühl dass
diese friedensdividende auch nach einem
schon angedrohten krieg durch vladimir
putin immer noch gerne kassiert werden
sollte
ich finde niemand muss sich dafür
entschuldigen auf die diplomatie und
erlangung von frieden über die
diplomatie gesetzt zu haben aber es
allemal musikchef tja aber man muss von
dem pferd absteigen wenn es tot ist und
der versuch über diplomatie diesen
konflikt zu lösen der ist für den moment
gescheitert naiv wäre es jetzt also
stehen zu bleiben und immer noch wie es
ein paar ganz wenige sagen aufzufordern
das dann irgendwelche runden tische die
längst von herrn putin mit der axt
erschlagen wurden zurück zu kehren jetzt
ist eine andere zeit angebrochen das ist
das was der bundeskanzler heute mit dem
ausspruch der zeitenwende der begriff
ist vielfach heute verwendet worden zum
ausdruck bringen wollte und
ehrlicherweise das spüren wir doch auch
hier sonntagabend im zweiten deutschen
fernsehen wir besprechen militär
strategische fragen das ist eine
zeitenwende die wir hier alle gerade
miteinander erleben und unsere aufgabe
ist es aber eben den leuten jetzt nicht
einfach nur angst zu machen und zu sagen
alles wird ganz schlimm und es ist
ausweglos sondern die geschlossenheit
via kiesewetter richtig sagte heute im
parlament oder gerade auch mit den
internationalen partnern in der nato in
der europäischen union ist es etwas was
ja putin nicht einkalkuliert hat und
wenn sie mich vielleicht dieses eine
beispiel bringen lassen und heutigen tag
sind die innenminister der europäischen
union der 27 mitgliedstaaten zusammen
gekommen und was über jahre undenkbar
schien dass wir uns noch dazu
kurzfristig und unbürokratisch auf einen
gemeinsamen vorteil mechanismus für
geflüchtete oder in dem fall muss man
wohl eher sein vertriebene menschen ein
was sagen dass ich nie möglich gewesen
und es heute innerhalb weniger stunden
vereinbart worden das ist der wirkliche
ausdruck der geschlossenheit die heute
europa den takt
frieden schaffen ohne waffen
würden sie sagen wann war bei ihnen
derzeit tun und wo war vielleicht auch
der ort an dem sie dachten dass das
jetzt nicht mehr gilt wann haben sie das
zum ersten mal gedacht
naja ultimativ in dieser woche letztlich
nicht erst beim einmarsch in die ukraine
sondern als der beschluss auch im
parlament dann vollzogen in moskau in
der staatsduma zur anerkennung der
separatisten regionen erfolgt ist aber
natürlich muss eine kluge politik sich
auch vorher immer mit allen
eventualitäten auseinander da sind dass
olaf scholz nach moskau gefahren ist zu
gesprächen heißt doch nicht dass er in
der blinden erwartung man müsste nur mal
mit diesen mann dort reden und dann
würde schon alles wieder gut werden
dorthin gefahren es sondern es geht auch
für den demokratischen westen um eine
nachweispflicht nach unseren spielregeln
alles versucht zu haben um dann auch
guten gewissens am ende sagen zu können
wir haben es versucht es hat nicht
funktioniert und wir können jetzt
unserer bevölkerung auch zumuten und
nachweisen dass die zumutung notwendig
ist dass jetzt andere schritte gegangen
werden müssen nur so kann der laden
jetzt bei uns auch zusammenbleiben das
halte ich für eine ganz wesentliche
voraussetzung
wir sind und da redet er von der spd bei
der union steht die geschlossenheit in
bezug auf diese fragen weniger zu
befürchten und trotzdem häcki die werte
auch an sie die frage ob es nicht fair
wäre noch einmal im blick zurück zu
sagen 2014 wäre eigentlich ein guter
zeitpunkt gewesen richtig alarmiert zu
sein robin alexander sprach ja das jahr
2008 an mit blick auf georgien und die
ukraine in die nato 2014 hatten die
amerikaner den vorschlag gemacht die
ukraine zu bewaffnen die ausbildung zu
verstärken also war das haben
deutschland und frankreich abgelehnt in
glauben und in der hoffnung dass
russland das anerkennt und als
deeskalation ansieht dass wir also nicht
der ukraine aufrüsten das hat sich im
nachhinein als fehler erwiesen das ist
leicht mehr haben immer angeboten
deeskalierend angeboten in richtung
moskau und das ist aber als zeichen der
schwäche verstanden werden so sehen wir
das heute das haben wir damals nicht so
gesehen haben es als europäischen weg
gesehen den minister prozess wo
frankreich deutschland und ukraine und
russland an einem tisch saßen allerdings
haben die russen sehr früh die
separatistenführer an den
verhandlungstisch geschickten hat die
ukraine gesagt das machen wir nicht mit
und dann hat russland das narrativ
verbreitet dort würden minderheiten
verfolgt oder die russischsprachigen
minderheit was auch falsch war es wurde
auch ein flugzeug abgeschossen mit 230
niederländern antworten und der mord im
tiergarten und wir weisen zwei
diplomaten aus das heißt also es gibt
eine ganze diskussionsreihe heute ist
der todestag von nimsoft sieben jahre
ist das her also wir waren eigentlich
diejenigen die auf deeskalation gesetzt
haben und putin soll das als zeichen der
schwäche und deswegen ist spät aber gut
dass wir diese wende vollzogen haben sie
sind zu zitieren mit dem satz
kiesewetter dass europa die ukraine den
russen quasi auf dem präsentierteller
hingelegt haben würden sie das heute
immer noch so formulieren es war die
gefahr sei 2014 dazu stehe ich auch aber
ich bin jemand der seit zwei jahren sagt
und hat teile da damals die einschätzung
von harnik vor einem guten jahr dass wir
die ukraine bewaffnen müssen ich habe
das immer wieder auch in der fraktion
vor gebracht aber wir waren natürlich
auf dem kurs der verhandlungen und es
ist eben so dass bestimmte wahrheiten
zeit brauchen und der fokus unserer
gesellschaft war eben eher auf cupid auf
die pandemie auf gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhang und auf ein geschäft und
auf eine sogenannte friedens liegen und
das ist auch nur zwei immer ein thema
gewesen ich kritisiere nord stream zwei
seit drei jahren dass wir das abschalten
müssen aber es geht jetzt nicht darum
klein-klein hinterher zu sagen dass man
recht hatte oder unrecht sondern es geht
darum dass endlich die vernunft
eingekehrt ist und dass all die signale
die wir hatten fokussiert werden müssen
und ich bin der festen überzeugung dass
die bundesrepublik jetzt auch einen
richtungswechsel machen muss um das
ganze zu finanzieren und um auch der
momentan beste erklärt da kommen wir auf
jeden fall noch dazu robin alexander was
denken sie wiegt schwerer das versagen
der politik oder steckt dahinter nicht
auch ein vielleicht trügerisches
weltbild einer gesamten generation die
dachte dass wir in einer friedliebenden
er jetzt vernunft gesteuerten und vor
allen dingen den frieden auch er
sehnenden zeit leben ich würde ungern in
seiner kulturkritik rutschen weil ich
hab das ja beobachtet wie merkel mit
putin verhandelt hat und die waren nicht
romantisch sie hatten also sie hat
einfach einen fehler gemacht ich glaube
auch persönlich sieht das heute auch so
sehen würde aber sie war nicht
romantisch wir haben natürlich in
unserer gesellschaft
ein heller hat sie gemacht putin zu
glauben aber dass oder ihnen ständig
angebote zu machen die
die deutsche idee die mit den personen
merkel steinmeier verbundes ist wie aus
diesen mann in einen kleinteiligen
verhandlungsprozess wir nehmen diese
sicherheitsinteressen reden da wieder
drüber so und dann setzt er sich hin und
zerreißt ist alles und sagt die ukraine
gibt es gar nicht ans volk damit ist
diese geschäftsgrundlage russland genau
dass das ist vorbei ja aber das hätte
man es haben leute vorher gewusst
deshalb steht um selbstkritik gut an ich
würde jetzt aber nicht so wir sind alle
zu weich so würde ich das nicht vom
tisch wischen karl schlögel sagt dass
mir kommt es so vor wie die späte
prüfung einer friedenszeit verwöhnten
generation heute in der welt ist ja karl
schlögel ist ein gutes beispiel dass der
historiker der wahnsinnig hinweis da hat
man von putin einen literaturpreis
bekommen und hat den zurückgegeben als
dass sie auf der krim waren und das ist
also jemand der der gelernt hat aber ist
natürlich auch ein großer experte und
wir haben natürlich
und damit fallen zwei sachen ineinander
einerseits haben wir diese
friedenssehnsucht wir haben auch einen
skeptischen blick auf jede art von
militär also beispiel auf dem parteitag
der spd in berlin bringt jemand einen
antrag an bundeswehr soll nicht in
schulen kommen und nicht sagen was man
da arbeiten kann oder wir haben die
korona pandemie und ein berliner
gesundheitsamt verbittet sich dass die
bundeswehr-soldaten bei der kontakt
verfolgung nachhelfen und sagen das ist
eine lehre aus dem zweiten weltkrieg
also solche sachen haben wir schon in
unserer gesellschaft und hinzu kam
natürlich dass die sich auch eingekauft
haben ein thema gerhard schröder thema
die stiftung auf die sich manuela
schwesig eingelassen hat die thema
schalke und und und dass das waren
unterschiedliche dinge die
zusammengeschlossen sind aber um das mal
ins positive zu wenden
mit den heutigen beschlüssen auch mit
dem was die eu kommission und die
bundesregierung und die franzosen und
andere in brüssel aufgesetzt haben da
ist damit schluss und ich glaube dass
das putin fast noch mehr überrascht als
die waffenlieferung weil es war doch
bisher so er konnte in syrien fast
bomben werfen und seine leute konnten
trotzdem in der côte d'azur oder urlaub
machen konnte die krim annektieren und
sie konnten trotzdem sich in münchen
operieren lassen so und jetzt 19 daher
ist vorbei und die sind auch diese
konstruktion die dort gewählt wurde die
russische zentralbank anzugehen das ist
schon etwas besonderes also auf dieser
nicht waffen ebene die man auch nicht um
schätzen darf hat die eu heute
wirklich einen sprung nach vorne gemacht
an
heute sagt man denn mal resilient ich
glaube man von der wehrhaftigkeit
selbstbewusstsein also da bin ich mal
gespannt wie das morgen und die nächsten
tage in moskau aufgenommen wird dh
beeindrucken wird ihnen jetzt weniger
auch die aufrüstung der deutschen
bundeswehr unser zwei prozent ziel das
erreichen wollen noch nicht gegen die
bundeswehr kämpfe ich gegen die nato das
hat doch frau weiß man gerade gesagt in
kiew gucken die strasse für strasse die
machen doch es geht auch nicht darum
dass wir den militärisch bekämpfen aber
er hatte eben diese leute kann er fertig
machen und bei uns keiner feier haben
sich operieren lassen seine seine kinder
zur schule schicken so und das ist jetzt
vorbei diese doppelmoral machen wir
nicht mehr wenn die eu das durch die
klasse sich vorgenommen hat und das ist
ein großer schritt nach vorn und dann
jetzt trotzdem die frage weil es ja auch
eine der wichtigen entscheidungen des
heutigen tages war dass wir erlöse
anders denken über unsere verein
verteidigungsfähigkeit und befähigung
100 milliarden für die deutsche
bundeswehr nicht nur einmalig sondern
ehrlich und wir wollen dass zwei prozent
ziel erreichen wie sehr wundern sie sich
und schütteln sich und sagen das ist
jetzt gut und richtig herr kiesewetter
hatte gerade gesagt wahrheiten brauchen
leider zeit und in den letzten jahren
waren wir einen tick schlafwandelt
unterwegs das kann man ruhig
unterstreichen robert habeck sagte diese
woche wir waren einen tick naiv das sind
schon mal gute aussagen reflektieren
aber jetzt gibt es das klingt nach vorne
zu richten und das heute war schon etwas
besonderes weil zum ausdruck gebracht
wird was politik sonst den sonntagsreden
immer wieder sagt nämlich das innere und
äußere sicherheit kern staatlichen
handelns sind aus dass man dafür
investieren und diesen sondervermögen
das ist etwas als verband treten wir
zeit den koalitionsverhandlungen davon
ein das war schwer damit umzugehen aber
diese woche sind da wie mehrere knoten
gelöst worden ich meine die
verteidigungsministerin hat bei ihrer
ersten rede im bundestag gesagt so geht
es nicht mehr aber nichtsdestotrotz war
schwierig in der regierung und christian
lindner war es diese woche der gesagt
hat in einem gespräch mit mir so geht es
nicht mehr als ich einmal die zahlen
aufgezeigt habe und gezeigt habe wie
marode diese bundeswehr ist und das war
so ein schockmoment parallel zum 1
angriff russlands auf die ukraine und
dann wurde das abgestimmt glas klingen
weil viele andere friedrich merz und
dann merkte ich es kommt etwas in
bewegung und das etwas in bewegung kommt
ist gut und mit diesem ansatz des
sondervermögens vor dem hintergrund der
schuldenbremse ist eine chance da die
bundeswehr wieder in den zustand der
einsatzfähigkeit zu bringen muss war so
wie man es braucht mit blick auf die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung nicht
klein ertüchtigung einsätze mali er 2001
landes und bündnisverteidigung mit
unseren partnern in der nato
glaubwürdigkeit nach innen und nach
außen und deswegen war das auch aus
sicht der bundeswehr heute ein
historischer tag bundeswehr endlich
wieder fähig auch zu auslandseinsätzen
und endlich wieder fähig das ist uns
nicht peinlich wird und die satiriker
freud in diesem land plus
wiedereinführung der wehrpflicht
kiesewetter ist es vorstellbar es geht
jetzt zuerst einmal darum dass wir
landes und bündnisverteidigung können
die wehrpflicht ist ein eingriff der
viel zeit braucht wir haben nicht mal
mit die kasernen dafür wir haben noch
250 kasernen die mit zwei mann und zwei
frau bitten ausgestattet sind und
geburtsjahrgang hat 700.000 menschen das
ist die falsche debatte es geht darum
die bundeswehr ihr parteifreund patrick
sensburg glaubt ist er nachfolger im amt
das war geschlagen als präsident im
reservistenverband und die reservisten
am natürlich ein besonderes interesse
jetzt weiter aktiv an der wiederaufbau
auch anders wer dabei zu sein aber
entscheidend ist dass wir einen guten
freiwilligendienst brauchen wir brauchen
das haben wir doch jetzt in der korona
pandemie gesehen eine art zivile reserve
die sich kümmert dass die
gesundheitsämter funktionieren dass die
blaulichtorganisationen funktionieren
und da ist die debatte über einen
freiwilligen großen gesellschafts dienst
gut wir deckeln doch unsere dienste bei
180.000 mit fsj freiwilliges soziales
jahr und bundesfreiwilligendienst aber
ich glaube mir bei meinem
geburtsjahrgang von zwei von 700.000
menschen das ist doch hinter lage sein
müsste dass wir 300 400 tausend
freiwillige zu finden dahin muss es
gehen wir wollen doch dass die leute das
gerne machen und die wehrpflicht
brauchen wir da nicht die ist ausgesetzt
für den fall der landes- und
bündnisverteidigung aber das hat zeit
und wir kümmern uns um die ausstattung
der bundeswehr
ich sage jetzt immer wieder erinnert
in den wahlkampfzeiten dass gäste
letztlich das gestrige des letzten
jahres war einer ihrer schlager zu sagen
dass wir diese zwei prozent nicht
brauchen das ist auch jetzt alles anders
ich habe wie die große mehrheit in
meiner partei ein pauschales 2% zähler
sozusagen zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts was ja auch kein
fester wert ist sondern sich jedes jahr
erinnert das habe ich immer für
unpolitisch gehalten so verfahren wie in
anderen politikbereichen auch nicht dass
wir sagen komme was wolle dieser anteil
soll es seien sieben entwicklungshilfe
ja die gleiche die wir aber auch nicht
erreichen aber
so und jetzt ist folgende situation
am ende muss es doch darum gehen in
welcher welt leben wir was sind die
erfordernisse was soll die rolle
deutschlands in dieser welt und in den
konflikten auf die wir treffen sein und
wir merken auch dass es teil der
zeitenwende jetzt passiert in unserer
unmittelbaren nachbarschaft in europa
etwas wir stehen vor einer zeit wir
wissen nicht wie lange sie ist aber sie
wird uns eine ganze weile begleiten
in der es auch um unsere unmittelbare
eigene sicherheit tatsächlich gehen wird
und die meisten empfinden auch wer nicht
vom fach ist doch in diesen tagen wir
müssen jetzt mehr für unsere sicherheit
tun wir treffen auf eine truppe die
darin wir überhaupt nicht bei aufrüstung
erstmal sondern die was ihre schiere
ausstattung angeht wenn wir dieser tage
hören geschickten männer und frauen und
baltic kommen das sind nicht einmal
ausreichend warme jacken zur verfügung
um dort nicht frieren zu müssen dann
kommen doch fast alle zu der
einschätzung des geht so erstmal nicht
und dafür jetzt eine vorsorge zu treffen
und zu sagen wir mobilisieren notwendige
mittel und wir tun das über die details
werden in den nächsten wochen noch viel
reden aber wir tun das über ein
sondervermögen
ist eine ganz wichtige aussage weil das
heißt nämlich auch weil es eigentlich
schon den nehmen es nicht aus dem
normalen haushalts aufkommen heraus wir
machen nicht ein verschiebebahnhof und
sagen so und soviel milliarden mehr für
die verteidigung und dafür jetzt weniger
leistungen für kinder und jugendliche
für erwerbslose menschen für um die
engagements weiterbildung für
klimaschutz und vieles andere mehr was
wir brauchen werden und das ist dass es
mir als sozialdemokratischer
abgeordneter wichtig ich habe kein
problem zu sagen die sicherheitslage
verändert sich und wir müssen mehr für
unsere sicherheit tun über meinen
sicherheitsbegriff und der meiner partei
sei ein umfassenderer erschöpft sich
nicht einfach nur in mail irischer
sicherung des staatsgebietes sondern
auch darin dass eine gesellschaft gerade
in der krisensituation zusammenhalten
muss und wenn die ärmsten die
schwächsten das gefühl haben müssen sie
sind die ersten leidtragenden sie fallen
hinten runter in ihre lebensperspektiven
werden nicht mehr berücksichtigt in dem
moment wo wladimir putin einen krieg vom
zaun bricht dann bricht uns die
einigkeit über die wir uns ebenso
gefreut haben ausländer deutlich der
zusagen beides gleichzeitig
funktionieren ja vorher was mir dass wir
noch mal wichtig ist hier sagen also der
knoten würde jetzt gelöst blick auf die
bundeswehr und die äußere sicherheit
aufgrund der aggression putins sein
agierens in der ukraine viel wichtiger
ist dass wir all das im blick haben was
in den nächsten jahren geschehen wird
wir haben jetzt noch den großen vorteil
einen us-präsidenten als transatlantiker
zu haben vielleicht den letzten wer weiß
was danach passiert wir europäer sind
aktuell recht schwach man spricht von
militärischen zwergen manche sagen wir
deutschen hätten die große geste
zipfelmütze aber nichtsdestotrotz wir
sind schwach in europa was unsere
sicherheitsarchitektur anbelangt und wir
müssen für die zeit auch nach beiden in
der lage sein unsere europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur selbst zu
gestalten und zu herzen mit all dem was
dazugehört und damit meine ich auch die
jeweils gesamtstaatliche
sicherheitsvorsorge also auch das was
wir immer erinnern machen stichwort
hacker angriffe sauber fake news und all
das was dazugehört und gleichermaßen
unserer partner im baltikum auch bei
diesen maßnahmen weniger militärisch zu
unterstützen also es geht nicht nur um
das hier und heute mit blick auf die
ukraine sondern es geht darum dass wir
uns selbst besser aufstellen
insbesondere auch vielleicht für eine
zeit nach präsident biden die frage noch
mal nach münster dann ist gleich
kiesewetter dran stichwort die in
deutsche gesellschaft muss insgesamt in
anderen kategorien denken marina
weisband und wir haben eben noch nicht
verstanden dass diese welt unsere
verteidigungskraft und einen schutz
braucht und dass wir auch über das wort
abschreckung noch mal nachdenken müssen
ich habe in meinem leben genug erlebt in
der ukraine in israel um zu wissen wie
wertvoll es ist ein militär zu haben das
diesen namen verdient und das
einsatzfähig ist ja ich würde auch
zustimmen dass wir eine
sicherheitsarchitektur brauchen die
tatsächlich nicht von einem großen
partner abhängig ist denn auch ich mache
mir große sorgen wenn ich mir die
eu-weit christian national ist angucke
die die republikaner jetzt unterwandert
haben praktisch ersetzt haben und die
wahrscheinlich die nächste wahl gewinnen
werden ich weiß nicht wie lange wir auf
die usa vertrauen können ja ist es
trotzdem der richtige zeitpunkt jetzt
mit so einem sondervermögen
heute brand zu gehen ich bin skeptisch
ich habe das gefühl der moment in dem
viele menschen sehr akut diese
aggression spüren wird ausgenutzt um
einen schritt zu machen der wie ich
finde ein zweiter schritt sein was
natürlich müssen wir geld in die hand
nehmen natürlich müssen wir die
bundeswehr aufbauen da werde ich nicht
widersprechen
aber wir haben auch strukturelle
probleme in dieser bundeswehr wir haben
milliarden gräber an großprojekten dort
wir haben gutachten die dem gerne aus
und haben trotzdem wir geben viel geld
aus und
was mir ganz persönlich unter den
fingern brennt ist wir haben
rechtsradikale netzwerke innerhalb
dieser bundeswehr deren aufklärung noch
nicht so offensiv passiert wie ich es
mir wünschen würde wenn ich jetzt höre
dass er etwa verdreifacht sich plötzlich
weil das heißt erst mal darf
verdreifachen sich waffen die geklaut
werden können und ich hätte gerne dass
dieser schritt im meer nicht zur
sofortigen verausgabung ich glaube das
muss man schon noch mal klarstellen das
ist jetzt nur rücken diese sukzessive
gerade für die langfristigen
investitionsmaßnahmen die schwierig
waren in den letzten jahren weil die
planungssicherheit nicht aber wir kaufen
ja nicht aus dem neckermann katalog die
sachen sondern vieles muss über jahre
und jahrzehnte abbezahlt werden man
kaufe das personal und den technischen
sachverstand mit dazu weil es auch die
ersatzteile nicht einfach irgendwo gibt
das find ich muss man schon noch mal
deutlich machen dass sind jetzt nicht
dieses jahrhundert 1100 milliarden die
in irgendwelchen waffensysteme sofort
reingehen und absolut richtiger
zwischenruf aber dennoch ist es für mich
notwendig über die struktur einer
solchen investition zu sprechen und auch
über die struktur der organisation der
sie zugeführt wird das wird uns auch
helfen ja wir wollen ja auch wer fähig
eine sehr fähige bundeswehr aber dafür
müssen wir eben nicht nur über geld
reden darauf möchte ich hinweisen
natürlich ist es so ein bisschen wieder
zu hören dass plötzlich geld geliehen
werden kann dass es da ist wenn der
politische wille da ist und das hätte
ich mir vor sehr langer zeit für ganz
andere projekt auch das gericht richtig
grünen-politikerin und entschuldige
zustimmen denn geld allein macht nicht
alles besser das thema strukturen und
verfahren kernthema und das wird jetzt
auch die neue verteidigungsministerin
von haben sechs milliarden sind daran
der tage im amt die wird da jetzt auch
mit umgehen müssen also nur geld
ausgeben wird nicht helfen es geht um
strategie es geht um die frage konflikt
bild es geht um die frage wie soll die
künftige bundeswehr aus schauen da gibt
es vorschläge zu strukturellen
veränderungen gerade mit blick auf die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung und
keine sorge das ist nur große
hausaufgaben eine große aufgabe für die
verteidigungs ministerin und ich bin
dabei also nur mal 100 milliarden zur
verfügung zu stellen aber das reicht bei
weitem nicht aus dass wir die
herausforderung für die nächsten ein
zwei jahre es geht um ein sofortprogramm
um unmittelbar von der bekleidung helm
schutzwesten munition dinge zur
verfügung zu stellen aber gerade die
langzeitprojekte die müssen geordnet
aufgesetzt werden weil aus der erfahrung
kann man sagen da lief nicht immer alles
gut was gut gemeint waren und genau so
macht er auch ursula von der leyen
darauf aufmerksam als sie noch im amt
der verteidigungsministerin war das
offensichtlich auch der eine oder andere
bundeswehrsoldat erstmal noch gefragt
werden muss west geistes kind er ist ich
würde wahnsinnig gern zum schluss der
runde noch mal auf das thema kommen was
es am ende bedeutet
jetzt eben auch für einzelne parteien in
der politik bedeutet so große
veränderungen zu machen ich habe es zu
beginn der sendung schon an rissen robin
alexander die
sozialdemokratie wird sich dem thema
rüstung widmen müssen die fdp wirklich
schon auch gerne noch mal ich hab jetzt
schon zweimal versucht zu wort zu kommen
sie haben versucht zu wort zu kommen
hätte die retter dann kommen sie zu wort
und dann vergesse ich jetzt einfach mal
einen gedanken sie brauchen nicht
vergessen weil ihr wichtig ist aber ich
glaube wir erleben gerade diesen
paradigmenwechsel auch hier vor ort im
wahlkampf im letzten jahr hat kevin
kühler noch gesagt zwei prozent heisst
aufrüstung und heute und da bin ich sehr
dankbar sehen wir angesichts des drucks
dass es vernunft nun einkehrt und
friedrich merz hat nicht umsonst
angeboten dass wir als union das
übergreifend unterstützen und wenn wir
jetzt hören dass die bundeswehr hier
große projekte hat dann müssen wir das
im parlament auch diskutieren und das
thema sondervermögen ist gut aber es
muss parlamentarisch beraten werden und
was das thema hingucken bei der
bundeswehr angeht kann ich sehr klar
sagen dass mit der aufwertung des
militärischen abschirmdienstes und der
übergabe kritischer leute an den
verfassungsschutz ein wahnsinns
fortschritt erreicht wurde in den
letzten vier jahren da müssen wir
wirklich auch weiterhin die neue
bundesregierung hinschauen aber ich
denke dass wir da auf einem sehr guten
weg hinschauen haben wir jetzt gemacht
und fragen noch mal robin alexander da
sind ein paar kegel umgefallen wie waren
ziemlich groß die fdp wird viele
schulden machen müssen die spd befasst
sich mit der verteidigungspolitik dieses
landes und die grünen werden wieder über
kohle und atom nachdenken müssen
denken sie dass die ampel das durchhält
die ampel hat ja erst mal was geschafft
also dass die ebenso kurzer zeit an die
realität heran kommen das kann man
natürlich beschreiben warum waren sie
früher so weit weg bis vor kurzem aber
der schritt ist er erst mal
beeindruckend und wenn man auf der ebene
weiter macht kann sich das noch
entwickeln aber tatsächlich alle
parteien ich würde auch die die union
übrigens da genauer einnehmen müssen
bestimmte liebgewordene identitäten
nochmal überdenken also dieses
sondervermögen ist natürlich ein trick
dass man nicht darüber sprechen wir sind
schon eher das sind schulden sind und
natürlich irgendwann werden ausgaben für
bundeswehr in konkurrenz zu anderen
ausgaben geraten das kann gar nicht
anders sein ja aber auch die union wird
das bedenken müssen und die grünen
werden bedenken müssen wir haben bis
jetzt eine energiewende gemacht wo wir
erneuerbare aufgebaut haben und gas als
reserve hatten jetzt gibt es ein sehr
gutes argument für die grünen bei den
erneuerbaren schneller zu werden aber
was macht man denn als reserve und ist
es wirklich klug wie heute der
sozialdemokrat wollte schon sagt wieder
in die kohle zu gehen oder sollte man
nicht überlegen wie es andere länder
machen weil es war interessant die
gründe zu hören war robert habeck sagte
er würde die verlängerung auch der
atomkraftwerke annalena baerbock gerade
in dieser sendung im interview sagt auch
das ist ein preis deswegen kohle
verlängern müssen vom ergeben hat bei
der atomenergie nämlich dass es für die
nächste heizsaison keinen beitrag
leisten
aber das wird wirklich interessante
debatte wenn man mal die überlegung ist
doch wir haben doch jetzt alle gelernt
co2 ist das wo man ganz schnell von
runter muss und wir haben uns immer
betrogen es geht über gas geht jetzt
nicht mehr gas geopolitisch und vorher
eigentlich auch nicht und die frage
fährt man jetzt die meiler hoch sogar
die braunkohle meiler die heute im blick
hat oder baut man keine neuen akw ist
aber steigt vielleicht etwas langsamer
auf ich glaube wenn die ampeln in diesem
realität drive bleibt und wenn wir genau
darüber sprechen weil historische tag
bleiben besser hätte man es nicht
zusammenfassen können ich darf mich ganz
herzlich bedanken bei ihnen für diese
runde heute danke auch nach münster
unbedingt zu marina weisband und es geht
dann mache ich mir einfach weiter im
programm wir sehen uns nächsten
donnerstag wieder wenn sie mit gleiche
stelle gleiche
[Musik]